انضم الينا من بيروت الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجيه العميد حنا اهلا بك عميد
الياس من ناحيه الاستراتيجيه الان
قرار تزويد اوكرانيا بهذه الذخائر
العنقوديه كيف تقراه
مياده هو ليس بالقرار الاستراتيجي لانه
القنابل العنقوديه لن تكون نقطه التحول
استراتيجيه في مسار الحرب الاف 16 قد تكون
صواريخ بعيده المدى 300 كيلو متر قد تكون
الحاله الميدانيه اليوم تتطلب هذا الامر
لعده اسباب اولا النقص في الذخيره العاديه
لمدافع 155 ملي متر وتوفر هذه الذخيره في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه 4.7 مليون
قذيفه 500 مليون قذيفه صغيره او البومبليت
كما يقال هذا متوفر اثنين القانون الدولي
يسمح بذلك وحتى القانون الامريكي بقرار من
الرئيس يمكن تزويدها لانها تستهدف منطقه
يعني هي تستهدف منطقه ولا تستهدف هدف نقط
معين في هذا الظرف الميداني هذا الامر قد
يكون مساعدا بالحد الادنى لتوفير الذخائر
من القذائف 155 التي فيها نقص كبير لدى كل
الغرب وحتى لدى روسيه يعني دوليا فقط هناك
يعني حوالي 111 دوله تعارض وموقعه
الاتفاقيات عدم استخدام القنابل العنقوديه
الامريكيا ايضا هناك كذلك القانون فيما
يتعلق بالنسبه واحد الى اثنين في المئه
ولكن القاره تخذ اليوم عندما نقول انه
قرار غير استراتيجي من ناحيه احداث فارق
هل نقصد انه لن يؤثر في شكل المعركه
والهجوم المضاد الاوكراني
لا سيؤثر حد ما سيؤثر لانه يعطي امكانيه
القصف في العمق هو
يهدف الى ضرب عناصر مشاه عناصر مختبئه مع
انه هذه القذيفه او القذيفه الصغيره
البومبليت هي تنفجر عند الصدامها بالارض
يعني كي تكون فعاله يجب ان تسقط داخل
الخنادق ولكن المهم اليوم
للهجوم العكسي الاوكراني هو الحمايه
الجويه
وما يسمى بالحرب الالكترونيه التي اليوم
تدرب او حسن الروس ادائهم الحمايه الجويه
المتنقله هذا امر مهم جدا وهذا الامر
سياتي قريبا من المانيا دفاعات جويه للقوى
المتنقله
هنا سنعود الى هذه الجزئيه تزويد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه المتطوره بعيده المدى التي
ينشدها ولكن قبل ذلك اليوم يتحدث عن
ضمانات مكتوبه من اوكرانيا فيما يتعلق
باستخدام القنابل العنقوديه ما مدى واقعيه
ذلك على الارض هل يمكن استخدامها بشكل
مسؤول
اليوم نتحدث يعني اوكرانيا ستستعملها ضد
القوات الروسيه المتواجده في اوكرانيا
اثنين الشعب الاوكراني المتواجد في
المناطق المحتله اذا صح التعبير هي ليست
موجوده منهم من ذهب الى الداخل الروسي
ومنهم من ترك الى الداخل الاوكراني فاذا
انت تستعملينها حكما وحصرا ضد القوات
الروسيه المتمركزه على طول 900 كم انا
اعتقد اليوم لا يمكن لاوكرانيا ان ترفض
الطلبه الامريكي لانه المصدر الاساسي
للسلاح الاوكراني هو من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وما تقرره الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وتطلب التعاوتي على اوكرانيا
يعني تنفذه وفي هذا الايطار بتقدم في
الميدان باسلحه متطوره بعيده المدى هل
سيحصل عليها
هو سيحصل عليها الاتاكانس يعني هي نفس
الصاروخ يطلق من الهايمرز مسافه 300 كيلو
متر بالاضافه الى 80 كم بالاضافه الى
250 كيلو متر وبدا الاستعمال فيه ضد على
سبيل المثال فاذا هذه الاسلحه بعيده المدى
هي لضرب العمق
واتباع استراتيجيه المنع الحرمان يعني
الجيش الروسي يعتمد على لوجستيه سوف يتم
حرمانه كما حصل في مدينه خرسون سابقا
اشكرك يا جزيلا الشكر العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي حدثنا من
بيروت